today the mat wall show Democrats wage
an actual war on Democracy by finally
indicting their Chief political rival
Donald Trump this outrageous Witch Hunt
is yet more evidence that the justice
system is a sham in this country
meanwhile DeSantis has pledged not to
cooperate with any extradition request
should Trump then Throw Down The
Gauntlet and refuse to surrender also
speaking of assaults on Democracy
leftist militants have staged two
insurrections at two different state
capitals in just the last 24 hours and
the trans activist goes on MSNBC to
explain why God quote made him trans
plus a scientist warns that AI might
become super intelligent and wipe out
all life on Earth do we need to add that
to our list of worries we'll talk about
all that and more today on the Matt
Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
you know inflation has consequences the
recent surge in gold prices is directly
tied to an extremely volatile Market
this is why gold has historically been a
great hedge against the stock market and
against inflation the only company then
that I trust to help you diversify into
gold is Birch gold group diversification
has never been more important precious
metals will always have inherent value
gold is a tangible and finite resource
uncontrolled by any single government or
any single financial institution as such
they cannot simply be printed on a
government's whim like paper currency
this gives precious metals a unique
advantage and results in numerous
benefits for investors Birch Golding can
also help you convert an IRA existing
Ira 401K into a tax sheltered IRA and
physical precious metals text Walsh to
989-898 to get a free info kit on gold
today with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews Birch gold is a company that I
trust to protect my future and yours
that's Walsh to
989898 today
last year a 37-year-old man named Marcus
Wright walked up to a woman who was
standing on the sidewalk talking on her
phone and for no discernible reason
brutally assaulted her it was a random
and senseless attack but not unexpected
after all Marcus Wright was a career
criminal with 36 arrests on his rap
sheet he had long ago made it clear that
he has absolutely no interest in
behaving like a civilized human being
he's going to continue committing crimes
and victimizing the innocent until the
justice system decides to stop him and
they still have him but in New York that
system is run by district attorney Alvin
Bragg another Soros Goblin who doesn't
believe in punishing criminals and
doesn't believe in protecting the
innocent and doesn't care about the
innocent right had been charged with
grand larceny a few months prior but
they reduced the crime to a misdemeanor
let him back out on the street a few
months before that he was given a
similar sweetheart deal on a robbery
charge and even after committing The
Assault on The Pedestrian he was still
released without bail
couple months a month after this latest
incident with Wright a 16 year old Thug
attacked a cop in a harlem subway
station punching him 20 times and this
assault occurred three days after the
same suspect was arrested for assaulting
and robbing somebody else
once again he was released without bail
and Bragg's office recommended that he'd
be released without bail again for the
assault on the officer
fast forward another few weeks in
September a sex predator named Justin
Washington allegedly sexually assaulted
five people in the span of a single day
near his homeless shelter
and this crime spree happened after he
had already been arrested for raping a
teenage relative he agreed in that case
to plead down in the ray case and he
received in exchange a 30-day jail
sentence and some probation
now these are just three examples pulled
at random actually the first three
examples that popped up when I Googled
it okay so these just just three
examples many many more which together
explain why during Bragg's first year in
office as D.A as Newsweek reports quote
Manhattan's seven major felony offenses
murder rape robbery assault burglary
grand larceny and grand larceny Auto
Rose by 26 percent to the highest since
2006. that was just in his first year in
office
this is a man Alvin Bragg who does not
place to put a mild Lake does not place
a high value on the Safety and Security
of his own Community a man who does not
think that Justice ought to involve
actually punishing dangerous criminals a
man who has never met a crime that he
takes seriously
unless of course the alleged culprit is
Donald Trump the daily wire reported
last night the news that I'm sure you've
heard by now quote a Manhattan Grand
Jury has indicted former president
Donald Trump in connection with
so-called hush money payments to Stormy
Daniels in 2016 according to her report
the felony indictment was filed under
seal by the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office according to the New
York Times and will likely be announced
within days at that point Trump will be
compelled to surrender and face
arraignment according to a report a
lawyer for Trump confirmed indictment to
the Associated Press the former
president is now the first former
president in U.S history to ever face
criminal charges
the lead prosecutors in the case met
with the grand jury on Thursday and read
them the criminal statutes before they
voted the report said a few hours later
the prosecutors walked into the County's
clerk count the court clerk's office and
began filing the indictment the news
comes as the Wall Street Journal
reported that district attorney Alvin
Bragg's office has also started
examining an alleged 150 000 payment to
former Playboy model Karen McDougall the
report said that prosecutors could use
the alleged hush money payment to
McDougall to bring additional potential
charges against Trump prosecutors could
also use mcdougall's evidence to try to
establish an alleged pattern of conduct
by the former president sense alleged
participants have claimed that Trump
played a key role in the deals according
to the report Okay so
we now know that the indictment has over
30 charges
and apparently brag is not done and you
can see why he has all this pent-up
energy to actually prosecute a crime I
mean he's so excited he's actually
indicting someone for a chance for a
change
um he hasn't prosecuted muggers robbers
carjackers murderers rapists the people
actually terrorizing his City and
causing immeasurable harm to the people
who live there hasn't done any of that
because he's been saving all of his
energy to bring Donald Trump to justice
for supposedly giving some money to some
floozy
there's no telling what other charges
are on the indictment it's still sealed
right now so we don't know perhaps Bragg
has also uncovered evidence of unpaid
parking tickets
um maybe maybe an overdue Blockbuster
rental from 1992.
maybe we need a separate grand jury for
those investigations who knows
it is uh it's a joke but it's not a
funny one because there's nothing funny
about a dying Republic and this is what
happens in a dying Republic we are
witnessing before our eyes the late
stages of a civilization
and that's the part where one political
party arrests and attempts to imprison
its Chief political rivals
you know for all the the hand-wringing
about attacks on our democracy
this is actually an attack on our
democracy it's hard to imagine a more
serious attack than this
trying to win an election by throwing
your opponent in prison like if you want
to attack democracy that's how you do it
it's not simply an attack on Democracy
it's actually the death of democracy
and it's happening at the hands of
people who of course claim to be
democracy's greatest champions
of course
you know there might there might be more
to this
um Democrats are soulless and corrupt
but they aren't generally idiots
so they're certainly aware of the same
fact that we all recognize which is that
nothing could possibly help Donald
Trump's primary campaign more than this
and his coming mug shot photo because
they're going to do the whole deal
they're going to arrest him uh uh
fingerprints mug shot everything and
when that photo is is uh is taken and
released just on its own becomes one of
the most powerful and compelling images
in the history of American politics
powerful and compelling in Trump's favor
as it should be
so it's far too early to say that this
move by Bragg has sealed the nomination
for Trump you know I'm not going to say
that it's that it's one in the
nomination because it's just it's so
early and we also know that people uh
people forget things I mean you could
have a story we've seen this many times
a story that's the biggest thing in the
world for
36 hours and then everyone forgets about
it six months later it's like it never
happened so
um that also factors into this but
it this definitely has considerably
expanded the gap
between Trump and second place in the
race for the GOP nomination
and the Democrats know this
okay we all know this and we're saying
it it's not like they don't it's not
like they don't know it's they're aware
of that political reality
is that part of the game then
are they operating on the theory that
the indictment will help Trump in the
primary
and they want to help him because they
want to run against them but it will
hurt him in the general thereby ensuring
Biden's reelection
you know is that the theory whether that
theory is true or not
is that what they're they're doing
so is this simply an act of mindless
political Vengeance without concern for
the political impact it might have or is
it something more strategic
and this really comes down to the
question of whether or not you believe
that Democrats are dumber than they are
corrupt and if you believe that you'll
probably assume the former this is
Mindless political Vengeance with no
other strategy in place now if you
believe that they're more corrupt than
they are dumb you'll assume the latter
that this is also a political play
and I tend to assume the latter they're
more corrupt than they are dumb
but whatever the motivation well we
absolutely know for sure is that none of
this would be happening if the alleged
culprit Behind These alleged
quote-unquote crimes was named Donald
Smith rather than Donald Trump
because as we've established Brad can't
be bothered to throw the book at actual
child rapists and armed robbers
he certainly wouldn't waste his time on
this Ticky tack nonsense if not for the
fact that Trump is the target
that's what we know that's all we need
to know and that's what makes this a
historic outrage
and yet more evidence that the justice
system does not exist in this country
it's not a two-tier justice system it's
not a Justice and that operates on a
double standard there is no justice
system there's no system in place to
enact protect and preserve Justice that
no longer exists
in fact
it's quite appropriate that Trump's
arrest would come uh now at the
conclusion of a 24-hour period where
leftists militants were storming state
capitals they stormed two State Capitol
Buildings in 24 hours
first there were the trans activists
invading the uh the Kentucky Capital to
defend their right to castrate and
sterilize young children and then
yesterday afternoon an angry mob of
leftists in Tennessee stormed our state
capitol here in Nashville
um calling for gun control
it was a rare occasion where
insurrectionists were demanding fewer
rights rather than more they were
storming the capital to say take our
rights away we don't want them please
take them
here's some of the footage of that scene
check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
follow me
[Applause]
well there's just no way around it that
is an Insurrection according to the
standards that have been set everyone
involved should be hunted down arrested
and thrown in prison for years
yet as expected the media has not
condemned the actions of these
insurrectionists they have not solemnly
declared that uh what was yesterday
March 30th March 30th will now live in
the national memory as a date more
tragic than 9 11. they haven't said any
of that instead they've reported on the
Insurrection like this watch
protesters flooded the state capitol
building today take a look you can see
young kids among those holding signs
demanding protection and calling for the
end of gun violence after the horrific
shooting at the Covenant School on
Monday which left three children and
three staff members dead and that's
where NBC's Lindsey Reiser joins us from
the state capitol in Nashville Lindsay I
know you have been talking to people
there at memorials at the vigil
yesterday now at this protest what are
they telling you
that Chris hundreds of people showed up
today I mean probably about 1500 maybe
even upwards of that showing out a lot
of young people a lot of young students
skipping school a lot of parents
bringing their young kids here as well
and I talked to the organizer of today's
event she's a single mom herself her
son's about to turn five and she said
she felt mobilized to act when she saw
this on Monday she put the flyer out
immediately you could tell she was
hardened to see the result today with
people singing songs confronting
lawmakers on their way into the general
assembly today calling for some kind of
gun reform
in other words it was a mostly peaceful
insurrection
but you know the media is allowed to be
absurdly biased and it's allowed to be
run by partisan hacks it shouldn't be
but it's allowed to be
the justice system on the other hand is
supposed to enforce the law equally and
fairly without respect to politics and
ideology yeah we all know that the
Tennessee Insurrection will not be
prosecuted
like January 6. in fact it almost
certainly won't be prosecuted at all
just as no other politician and
certainly no other former president or
presidential candidate will be held to
the same legal standard that Trump is
being held to
and that's because again there is no
justice system there is a system yes
there is the the system
but Justice is not its aim
now let's get to our five headlines
okay we'll start with a little bit more
on the Trump indictment this is from the
daily wire Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
quickly responded to news on Thursday
that former president Donald Trump had
been indicted by a Manhattan grand jury
by calling it a question the legitimacy
of the case and saying the state will
not assist in extradition request
um the Santa Senate statement the
webisation of the legal system to
advance a political agenda turns the
rule of law on its head it's Un-American
the Soros back Manhattan district
attorney has consistently bent the law
to downgrade felonies and to excuse
criminal misconduct yet now he is
stretching the law to Target a political
opponent Florida will not assist in an
extradition request given the
questionable circumstances at issue with
this Soros back Manhattan prosecutor and
his political agenda uh this is a very
good statement you know his when when
news first broke a couple weeks ago that
Trump might be arrested and uh DeSantis
put a statement out or he addressed it
it wasn't even stable he put his address
as press conference and I was uh if you
watched Joe you know I was critical of
his the way he initially addressed it I
thought he needed to come out stronger
and he also should say that he's not
going to participate in any extradition
and now now that the arrest has actually
happened
um he has put this statement out I think
it's an excellent statement uh now you
know there are the the kind of the Trump
lackeys on Twitter that are still
complaining even about this okay this is
a harsh condemnation and even saying
he's going to go to bat to protect Trump
here and uh is still you know they're
the mostly the paid Trump supporters on
Twitter saying well it's not good enough
because he didn't say his name say his
name
well we know that literally no matter
what DeSantis does they're going to
complain I mean he is after all
inarguably DeSantis is the most
effective Republican governor in the
country and one of the most effective in
our lifetimes uh that's not an arguable
statement I know it even does and yet
they still find a reason to hate him so
it's no surprise here but
um
the fact that he's saying they're not
going to participate in any kind of
extradition uh request
not going to um go along with it is huge
now on the other hand it kind of It kind
of puts the ball back in Trump's court
because what we're being told so far is
that Trump plans to surrender
um and uh but but he shouldn't like if
we're going to have this fight let's
have it okay we keep hearing how this
the crossing of the Rubicon this is a
threshold has been crossed uh throwing
down the gauntlet whatever
um
metaphor you want to use
and I agree with that and so that means
let's have the fight
let's do it I don't know where it goes I
don't know where it goes from there if
you have the governor saying I'm not
going to participate in extradition you
have Trump say I'm not going to
surrender where does that go what
happens next who who knows exactly
um
well where it goes is someone has to
back down
or not
and to me that's clearly the right move
here okay that's how you fight back
against this that's how you fight back
you refuse to surrender you know if this
is an unjust political persecution which
it is
then you can't cooperate with it
now if you've actually committed a crime
and uh or even your even even if you are
sort of legitimately suspected of
community you didn't commit it let's say
you're Innocent but you've been you're
you're suspected of committing the crime
and you know that this is a that this is
a uh a true attempt by the legal system
to you know adjudicate this and figure
out what's going on well then yeah the
right thing to do is surrender but in
this case
this is all this is entirely just a a
political charade this is a political
game and everybody knows that
so I don't think you surrender and I
don't think you go along with it
but then Trump also has to weigh you
know okay he could he could thread on
The Gauntlet and say I'm not going to
surrender I will not go along with this
okay not gonna happen
um
if he does if he does that then there's
a chance you don't get the mug shot
photo uh you don't get the photo of the
the perp walk and handcuffs which are
going to be very powerful political
images
um but I think he needs to be willing to
sacrifice that
in order to have this fight
that would be my view of it
next we have Charlotte Clymer who's a
trans activist
um interesting thing about Charlotte
Clymer is that
just a few years ago he was Charles
climber a male feminist activist who as
laid out by uh Greg price on Twitter
yesterday is a male feminist who got
canceled by his own side for being a
rageous obnoxious you know raging
obnoxious uh uh scumbag jerk basically
his own side canceled him years ago
there was even a hashtag that got going
called stop climber
because this again people on his side
left us who said that he's uh This
creepy male feminist guy who's obnoxious
to women he's an a-hole and all the rest
of it
so climber then sort of disappears and
then re-emerges as a woman he rebrands
himself as a woman and now he's a hero
again
he was on the outs as a male feminist
then says oh you know what turns out I'm
a woman I I have looked inside myself
and discovered as it turns out that I am
uh that deep inside I'm really a woman
and just like that
his career as an activist has taken off
again no one in his side is critical of
all the critics all the people that were
critic criticizing Charles Clymer back
in 2015 are gone they're not saying
anything about it anymore because now
he's Untouchable because he's trans
many such cases okay this is this is the
the safest career path for creepy
obnoxious men on the left is this
just come out and say you're a woman
you don't have to commit to it okay you
don't have to actually get the surgery
or even take the drugs just grow your
hair out pull it back in a ponytail and
uh and you know wear a headband or
something and walk outside and say
you're a woman that's it all the
criticism is gone simple as that
that's the story of
quote unquote Charlotte Clymer and uh
as this untouchable now
um
activist he appeared on MSNBC this week
and I want you to hear this part in
particular listen to this
I think children are only unsafe at drag
shows when a shooter shows up to kill
them that's right that's where the
threat is I would challenge anyone just
to get to know trans people we are a
vibrant diverse Community as diverse as
anyone else gone from the great state of
Texas I served in the military I go to
church every Sunday my faith is very
important to me but God Made Me In Her
Image God made me transgender
and to see these people so cynically
weaponize this and exploit these
children's debts and their teachers
debts
it breaks my heart I wonder what those
families are thinking right now what do
you what do you feel when you have
somebody like Michael Knowles at CPAC we
need to eradicate transgenderism and
when somebody like Tucker Carlson says
that transgender people are at war with
Christians I can't see Christ in their
words that's for damn sure I can't see
where the biblical principles of loving
your neighbor
and walk in the walk with Christ that
they can see I can't see what they're
seeing right now because that son of
Christ it's not
there's our here's our expert on our on
biblical New Testament exegesis who's
someone who's you know obviously in a
position to speak for what uh what what
for for Jesus Christ
is it let me ask you uh climber is it of
Christ is it of Christ to be uh an
obnoxious a-hole to the extent that your
own side hates you and then to turn
around and appropriate uh the the female
identity to put yourself above criticism
is that is that of Christ
and before we even get to the nonsense
the climber was uh vomiting out of his
lying mouth
look at the screen maybe you notice that
on the screen maybe you notice the words
on on the screen right there the
headline transgender shooting suspect
Sparks outrage on the right
well yes yes it did you got us guilty as
charged uh that's true our our outrage
was indeed sparked by the murder of
children
yeah that's uh that's us you know this
conservative snowflakes
overly sensitive we get we get we get
very upset when Psychopaths go and
murder children yeah we are we're very
upset about that
that is always an effective way to make
us outraged is to murder children
so you people get outraged by being
misgendered okay you get outraged if
somebody uses a pronoun you don't like
we get outraged by the Mass Slaughter of
children Mass Slaughter of children by
the way in any form so the Mass
Slaughter of children at school we get
out from each other the best Slaughter
of children at an abortion clinic we get
outraged by that
and so that's where we differ I suppose
that effect is is it's true that's one
of the major dividing lines in the
culture
do you oppose the mass murder of
children or not and there is an entire
side of the political divide that not
only doesn't oppose it but openly
advocates for the Mass Slaughter of
children especially when it happens in
an abortion clinic
so I do appreciate how MSNBC is
admitting I mean they're admitting that
only conservatives are outraged by this
which is also true
as for the rest of it no God didn't uh
make you transgender
you know God God made you since since
you want to take the conversation in
this direction
and once again we see this dichotomy
here where on the left they're
constantly accusing the right of uh
Bible thumping and of you know all of
our positions we only take those
positions because it's what our religion
told us
meanwhile as I'm always reminding you
in any of these conversations whether
it's transgenderism or abortion or even
gay marriage
you know if there's a debate between the
two sides and religion is brought into
it and the Bible is brought into it and
Jesus is brought into it 99 of the time
it's the left bringing that into the
conversation
and the game is that they bring into the
conversation if we respond by saying
well no because the Bible says this
we'll stop throwing the Bible at me you
bible thumper
since you bring this up no God did not
uh make you transgender God made you a
male that's how you were made that's
what you were made and that's also what
you recognized yourself to be uh until
just a few years ago
that is what you were made to be and
that's what makes transgender one of the
things that makes the transgender
ideology uh so Insidious
is that it encourages people to reject
their god-given nature what God has
actually made them to be
which brings us to another point I
wanted to make quickly on the on the on
the trans topic we talked about those
insurrectionists in uh
Kentucky we had them in Tennessee we had
them in Kentucky
and in Kentucky they invaded the Capitol
building and they were uh screaming and
crying and all the rest of it shouting
slogans uh they also held what they
called a die in and so this is where
they all just splayed out on the ground
it looked much like an airport terminal
people all lying on the ground uh except
in this case they're pretending to be
dead because they're making the point
trying to make the point that you know
those of us who oppose transgenderism we
are killing trans people
and that's uh we're we're contributing
to a genocide of trans people
but this is where we have to
we have to State the fact
because it's true
that
you know the greatest threat to the life
of a transgender person you take any
individual trans identified person
the greatest threat to that person's
life
is that person himself
okay if a trans person is going to be
killed
most likely
he's going to die at his own hands the
person most likely to kill a trans
person is himself
and that's what that's what the suicide
rate tells us that's just that's a
statistical fact
you know the number of trans people who
are murdered by somebody else
infinitesimally small that's an
infinitesimally small percentage and as
we've talked about the number of trans
people killed allegedly for being Trans
in like an actual hate crime even
smaller it's smaller than in you take
the infinitesimal uh you know slice of
of trans death that is murder it's an
even it's an even smaller slice of that
slice that is an actual Hager
um but
as everybody agrees and knows there are
trans people and many more trans people
uh being killed every single year it's
just that in almost all those cases
they're killing themselves
because the
you know the uh the trans suicide rate
is somewhere around 40 percent
and the rate of trans people who report
having considered suicide is much
greater it's much more than half
and it depends on what study you look at
and which poll or survey you look at but
matter no matter where you're looking
for your data
suicidal ideation among trans people is
by Far and Away the majority of them
um that's where the threat lies
those are the people killing trans
people themselves
this this catastrophically High suicide
rate that is historically unprecedented
and all of the explanations that the
trans activists themselves give for this
suicide rate they're the ones who they
also are the ones who bring that up most
of the time they're going to bring up
the the fact that uh that the trans
suicide rate is so high
all the explanations they give for that
high suicide rate make no sense and they
fall apart the second you start to
scrutinize those arguments because what
are they going to tell us they're going
to say well this only is happening
because trans people are bullied and
persecuted and all the rest of it
well if that was the case then we should
see that a society becomes more
accepting of transgenderism that the
suicide rate plummets and that is not
happening at all
in fact we live in a society right now
where trans people are celebrated are
breathlessly celebrated by all of the
major institutions in our country and uh
they're throwing parades in the street
they're celebrating them constantly and
that apparently has done nothing really
to bring the suicide rate down
and then you compare that to the
experiences of any group of people
historically any other demographic who
experienced real persecution I'm talking
about enslavement Mass execution Genesis
actual genocides like rounding you up
and throwing you into a death camp kind
of genocide you look at you look at
groups of people that experience those
and unfortunately there have been many
groups historically who have gone
through that
none of them had a suicide rate of 40 or
even close to it
or even anywhere close to it in fact in
many cases
it was the opposite effect in many cases
there's there's the effect of the
suicide rate going down in the face of
persecution
as the people in that group uh you know
rally around each other and uh and and
all of that so if anything that's where
you see the trend
it's only with with trans people where
they allegedly respond to bullying uh
with a with a 40 suicide rate and what
that tells you is that it's got nothing
to do with anything external it's got
nothing to do with the environment it's
got nothing to do with anything that I'm
saying or that you say when you
criticize trans ideology it's something
it is it is it's it's rooted in the
despair that itself is rooted in a
person's inability to accept their own
inherent nature
that you know your inability or refusal
to accept that breeds Despair and then
that is what causes the suicide rate
all right
um
so this is a something a little bit
different from Fox News in artificial
intelligence expert with more than two
decades of experience studying AI safety
said that it said an open letter calling
for a six-month moratorium on developing
powerful AI systems does not go far
enough
elizer yadkowski a decision theorist at
the machine intelligence Research
Institute wrote in a recent op-ed that
the six-month pause in developing AI
systems more powerful than gpt4 called
for by Tesla CEO Elon Musk and hundreds
of other innovators and experts
understates the seriousness of the
situation he would go further
implementing a moratorium on new large
AI learning models that is indefinite
and worldwide so he wants an indefinite
moratorium on all of these um
AI systems he said in a letter powerful
AI system should be developed only once
we are confident that the effects will
be positive and their risk be manageable
the key issue is not human competitive
intelligence as the open letter puts it
it's what happens after AI gets uh
smarter than human intelligence
um
he says that yadkowski warns that there
is no proposed plan for dealing with a
super intelligence that decides the most
optimal solution to whatever problem it
is tasked with solving is annihilating
all life on Earth he also raises
concerns that ad researchers don't
actually know if learning models have
become self-aware and whether it's
ethical to own them if they are so
this is what he's claiming this is and
this is the concern that we're hearing
from people now is that we've got to be
very worried about AI because number one
uh they could become self-aware and
maybe they already are
these uh you know these chat Bots and
everything maybe they have a they they
are a conscious actually they they they
become their own Consciousness and then
once that happens then do they form
together to become some sort of super
intelligence that as he says uh
annihilates all life on Earth because
maybe the robots would say well all
these problems that we're supposed to be
solving probably the simplest solution
is just to uh start Exterminating people
now
it's a one hand that's not an
implausible Theory because many of these
AI uh systems are being programmed by
leftists and we know for leftism that is
the solution these are these These are
eugenesis and this is what they believe
is they they believe that the way you
solve a lot of these problems is by
reducing the number of people on Earth
they say one of the biggest problems
that we face right now according to them
is the fact that there are too many
people on earth and so we have to reduce
the number
um because people are uh you know a
cancerous blight on Mother Earth
so it in a certain way you can you can
um anticipate AI being programmed that
way
but I still am not terribly concerned
about AI wiping out all life on Earth
okay that's not the risk
um but I am still worried about AI I
think it's a it's a very serious concern
my worry though is not that it kills
people
okay but that it makes life for people
miserable
it doesn't it doesn't kill humans
instead it kills the human spirit
that's what we should be concerned about
with AI technology and with with uh with
with much of modern technology
doesn't mean we want to live in the
Stone Age
but this is the downside it's not this
is not it's not a sci-fi movie where
where a chat bot becomes look none of
these chat Bots are self-aware and Siri
on your iPhone is not is not self-aware
this is not happening
uh as far as we know it's not possible
for inorganic matter to develop
Consciousness there's no indication at
all that that's even physically possible
all we have are the Sci-Fi films and
books that we all grew up with all these
stories and so we're all even these
scientists and these AI theorists they
are heavily influenced by fiction
and uh and so they're coming up with
this story that's really rooted in that
so that's not going to happen Okay the
robot's not becoming self-aware they're
not going to band together it's not
Terminator they're not going to try to
enslave us
um
but what is going to happen and what is
happening right now is that this
technology
makes human beings increasingly useless
and obsolete
okay by taking away jobs as we get
self-driving cars and you don't need
people driving cars anymore you don't
need truck drivers you don't need you
know we so get rid of that get rid of
that uh and as the um as the chat Bots
and these kinds of systems are able to
start like composing
um in fact I just read the other day
that BuzzFeed has already started using
AI to generate its articles which means
we don't need BuzzFeed uh writers
anymore and I know that that in and of
itself seems like more of a perk than a
downside that we're getting rid of
BuzzFeed writers but it just shows like
this is the trend making human beings
obsolete
um taking away jobs taking away work
making you know and then also kind of
paradoxically at the same time
uh also making life far too easy
it takes your job away it's not easy but
in general kind of like
all this technological advancement
removing all resistance from life
prioritizing efficiency and convenience
above everything else you don't have to
work for anything it's all just handed
to you
um and I think that also breeds
boredom which breeds despair uh so it's
it's kind of on a deeper level but I
think that's what we need to be
concerned about when it comes to AI
I also wanted to mention this uh from
daily wire anthropology researcher at
the University of Pittsburgh was
incredulous after her Champion female
Collegiates one of Riley Gaines pinned
him on a basic question about the
biological difference between men and
women which prompted raucous laughter
from students gains a recent University
of Kentucky graduate who tied for fifth
place with transgender identifying
swimmer Leah Thomas at the NCAA
Championship last year recently
delivered a talk at the University of
Pittsburgh about men and women sports to
a room of pact with students
Gabby Yearwood a senior lecturer at the
school's anthropology department
rejected the notion that researchers can
use skeletal evidence to determine a
deceased person's sex
so this is
you know this this is always going to be
one of one of the many kind of mic drop
rejoinders that you can have if you're
on the pro sanity side in the gender
discussion uh is is by asking look
however somebody identifies they die
they're dug up their bones are dug up by
uh by archaeologists or anthropologists
um
a hundred years from now what are those
scientists going to say about that
person's sex
and
that's definitive because they will be
able to determine based on that the sex
the gender identity won't mean anything
anymore but
this person tried to claim uh the
opposite let's watch this moment
I actually have a question for you you
being an anthropologist which
anthropology is the study of human
civilization
so if you were to dig up a human to
humans and 100 years from now both men
and women could you tell the difference
strictly off of Bones yeah because
there's a migraine
I'm sorry women huh
being laughed at if I'm the expert in
the room have any of you been to
archaeological sites with any of you
studied biological anthropology
I've got over 150 years of data
I'm just I'm just curious as to why I'm
being laughed at when I I actually
I believe it or not I have put a lot of
research into this because I I'm not
interested
anymore I'm just telling you that I have
considered all viewpoints
okay he never explains how that could
possibly be the case uh well no you
can't you can't tell the sex at all but
and and
his his reasoning his defense of that is
why I have a PhD so I'm the expert so
this is what I say goes
this is the this is the kind of the Tony
fauci approach you know we've heard from
fauci that that he he is I am the
science he says I'm on the side if you
disagree with me you disagree with
science I represent science and uh and
this is how they all feel about
themselves they get the they get the
credentials they go and they uh get the
expensive piece of paper and now they
represent science so science is not
what it actually is which is a process
of understanding the physical world
that's all that science is it's the
process by which we come to understand
uh phenomena in the physical world
that's that side
that's what it actually is but to these
people who call themselves scientists
it's it science is uh whatever they say
it's their own it's their own Viewpoint
and they are they are uh sort of sort of
avatars for science itself
um
but this is just total nonsense I mean
he he is denying
he's denying like the entire history of
anthropology and archeology
and you can go if you want to if you
want to check the facts here you can go
on Google and just look up countless
hundreds of stories thousands of stories
of scientists digging up some ancient
Bones from centuries ago and all the
things they're able to tell about that
person
um
because as it turns out
you know your sex is
a reality that is it's not just as we
have been
trying to establish it's not just about
hormones it's not about one individual
thing if you are a woman then your
entire body is you know attest to that
fact and as long as some part of your
body remains
then they'll be able to determine your
sex
all right one of the things before we
get to the comment section
unilad has this just a few decades ago
humans took a giant leap for mankind and
stepped foot on the moon now NASA is
planning to LEAP even further today
space agency announced the establishment
of the new Moon to Mars program office
at NASA headquarters in Washington which
would be tasked with Paving the way to
getting humans on Mars it comes
following the initial establishment of
the Moon to Mars program which plans to
send the first woman and first person of
color to the surface of the Moon and
help use what we learned there to
prepare for the trip to the red planet
so unfortunately our trip to the moon
has to be delayed a little bit because
we need to uh we need to check this box
of getting a woman and a black person on
the moon once we've done that then we
can actually proceed with actual space
exploration
um but the idea of going to Mars
I don't have to tell you that I love the
idea I think it's worth all the money
that it will cost and then some
uh I think that a new space age an
actual new space age
which is not just billionaires you know
flying up and orbiting the Earth one
time for a sightseeing tour I mean
that's good for them but that's not
spacious Space Age I'm talking about a
new space age of Discovery I think that
that that would
um be a part of how we save our
civilization and I really mean that and
I don't mean that it saves our
civilization because we can set up
colonies on mars or whatever because
I've that idea I've never totally
understood who would actually want to go
live there I know that I wouldn't
uh so the idea that well hey life on
Earth is unlivable this is this is a
theory life becomes unlivable in the
future so let's go to a place where it's
negative 80 degrees on average and the
atmosphere is toxic and you can't
breathe it and once every few years
there are massive dust storms that cover
the entire planets uh let's go there
instead because the Earth is a little I
never understood that no my point is
that it saves Humanity by giving us
something to strive for giving us
something to dream about and reach for
um like giving us something to do as a
as a as a civilization and it turns out
that it's not just individuals that need
things to do with their lives an entire
civilization needs that too you need
something to to point towards and strive
for uh you need goals right
and right now we really don't have any
so I think that this could help with
that it would also give us a triumphant
moment
like to actually land on Mars
so the for the first time human beings
stepping foot on another planet
this would be a triumphant Victory this
would be a historic moment
and in a good way
because we haven't had that I don't
think in my lifetime we've had that
not very many anyway
these days if you hear about this is a
historic moment
history will remember this moment it's
almost always something terrible like
the first president United States to be
arrested historic moment
yeah it's historic sure but it's just
it's a historic shame it's not a
historic Triumph and we haven't had that
we haven't really had that since uh
since the moon landing
which I wasn't alive for
and that would give us that so that's my
that's my pitch
for landing on Mars also would just be
really cool let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
hard rock music fan says best
cancellation ever these people on
airplanes somehow managed to even be
worse than the types of Travelers on
buses somehow I actually prefer to sit
in the middle seat and I'm still okay
with these rules perfectly rational and
acceptable but I'm sorry you prefer to
sit in the middle seat you prefer it
what kind of freak are you
this is actually you should be on some
kind of uh registry somewhere for I mean
no offense I don't mean any offense by
that but this is that is not that that's
that's a
you know I I we talk about a lot of many
different forms of perversion but that's
a deep one right there you prefer to sit
in the middle how could you prefer it
it's like objectively uh the the worst
place to be on the plane so you prefer
to have less space when someone says
someone says well you could have more
space or less space I'll take less
I'll take less price you know I'll take
less personal space I prefer to have
less yeah I prefer to be sandwiched in
between two smelly strangers I want that
that's what you're telling me
like do you prefer do you do you prefer
when you go to a a restaurant and they
spit in your food it's like would you
prefer that
thanks thanks for listening uh Max says
Matt's clearly never had his flight
delayed repeatedly over the course of a
day with the travel agency unable or
unwilling to provide for alternative
accommodations people will sleep at
airports because they're not at home and
nowhere near their home get over it
okay Max first of all there is no flying
or airport scenario that I have not
experienced okay I I practically live in
airports these days and so I've been
through all of that it's no excuse I
have been dead tired on like two hours
of sleep in four days just walking like
a zombie through airports and I don't
sleep because I'm I'm a grown man an
adult it is shameful and disgraceful to
sleep in front of strangers especially
in an environment that's not made for it
and also travel agency
what do you add do you do you use fax
machines too you have a travel agency do
those even exist anymore
uh maybe that's your problem maybe
that's why you're running into problems
because they're using a travel agency
from 1982
um
all right
Davin says Matt I feel like you're
starting to get the same disconnect from
people and that the people on MSM MSM
have I work full-time making 19 an hour
at 22 years old in my area Northern
Arizona making 19 is Fu money I'm having
minimal expenses to the point I only pay
for what I absolutely have to and I
still live not even paycheck to paycheck
but worse my family's the only reason
I'm not homeless all I've ever wanted in
life is to make a family and have kids
but at this rate I might be able to
afford to feed a child at 35. our values
are changing because liberals offer
values more accommodating to people
struggling through no or little fault of
their own
not to even mention the fact that a damn
speeding ticket for going 10 or 10 over
is a 300 ticket the margin of error for
us broke boys is so small almost any
fine from anywhere is enough to take
from what's served for dinner it takes
us half a year to recover from a fifteen
hundred dollar car repair Bill my point
of all this uh is don't give people like
me on your show for not wanting kids
when the problem is those of us that
want them literally can okay well Davin
you're you're 22 years old okay you're
20. let me it's not it's not a
competition okay but I was when I was 22
I was more broke than you are right now
and I also lived alone and I wasn't
homeless I just didn't live in any kind
of luxury whatsoever
um so you're 22. that's you know being
being broke and just like working
paycheck to paycheck and struggling to
get by that's what you're supposed to do
at 22. it's better to have that at 22.
um as as opposed to you know having life
be too easy like this this is the time
and right you're not you don't have kids
yet you're not married yet I assume
um and so it's and so you're in a
position where it's it's okay for you to
struggle because you don't have to bring
you know if you don't have dependents
that are depending on you
um you're only 22. so
you know when I talk about the value of
having a family and having kids
um
that could still very much apply to you
you're only 22 years old so you don't
need to write off having kids at 22
because you're struggling right now and
I understand again I understand the
struggles I went through it myself at
your age what I'm trying to tell you is
that you're very very young you got a
long uh you're just you're just starting
the early phases of young adulthood you
just got started you just became an
adult
practically like yesterday okay
um and so you don't need to write off
any of this
and you say at this rate you won't be
able to have kids until you're 35 you
won't have the money to afford them but
there's no reason why it has to continue
at this rate
okay you're making 19 bucks an hour 22
years old
um and you're you're assuming that your
rate of pay and your salary is going to
just continue uh Rising you know at a
rate commensurate with what's what's
happened so far but that's not the way
it has to work
you're just establishing yourself right
now and um
and building you know you're in the
early stages again of building your life
as a young adult
so there's no reason why at 22 you have
to consign yourself to this notion that
you you won't be able to start a family
at all or maybe not until your mid-30s
so take heart is what I'm what I'm
trying to say
and also uh I very much disagree with
the idea that liberals offer values that
are accommodating to people who are
struggling
liberal values left-wing values are
these are anti-human values they don't
accommodate anyone they don't care about
anyone
um
Gregor says I don't really agree with
Matt's defense of asking for the
manifesto here but
um not in other cases instead I would
make this argument we don't need the
manifesto when there's a common
understanding that something could exist
the races who shot up the supermarket
everyone who watched the video gets what
that was about publicizing the manifesto
adds nothing and risks copycats on the
other hand if there's a refusal to
acknowledge an obvious motivation then
the manifesto is critical especially if
it leads to the predictable and clearly
dishonest don't believe Your Lying Eyes
defense here the motivation is clear the
transness is a part of the equation
Christianity is part of the equation
both of these are denied by one side of
discourse this denial is just a smoke
screen defense only possible while the
manifesto is locked up
well I don't think that you said you
disagreated my argument but I think you
basically restated my argument I
I concur absolutely with you that that
yes that is maybe you you've put it
together more succinctly than I did
um so I'll give you credit for that but
that is the reason for releasing the
manifesto okay that's why there's
nothing inconsistent in saying that in
some of these past mass shootings there
was no reason really to release the
manifesto I still don't think like I'm
not in favor of the government hiding
these sorts of things at all
so when there's any kind of mass
shooting and people are killed and the
person who did it has written out their
reasons for doing it
I there's no scenario where I would be
okay with government authorities hiding
that from the public because the public
has a right to have access to that
but in other cases I think um
there's no reason for the media to go
out of the way to publicize it or
dissect it too much because as you say
it's it's like an established thing
nobody denies it
um whereas in this case
there are people who just
fundamentally deny
that this radical
trans agenda and the rhetoric that we
hear from institutions about the trans
issue that it has the effect of
radicalizing people and encouraging so
people that deny this absolutely and so
that's where the manifesto
comes into play
and finally Becca says the plane
etiquette was hilarious much needed
after all the horrible things currently
going on it wasn't supposed to be funny
is this is not only serious but uh when
it comes to behavior on planes or really
any time i'm dissecting etiquette it's
uh I'm never more serious than in those
moments so just to be totally clear and
you're also banned from the show
obviously
do you need a new show to watch I'm sure
you do considering that other than
succession and a handful of alien
documentaries most of what's out there
is absolute garbage not a handful of in
all of the alien documentaries are great
so that in succession a couple others so
if you like good shows you should check
out season two of The search with Ben
Shapiro a couple weeks ago Ben was
joined by comedian Russell Brand and
this week he sits down with the always
enjoyable Megyn Kelly here's a look at
their latest episode
when you first get married and your
spouse is is sick you're like oh my God
I'll take care of you this is so I feel
so bad for you now when you have kids
and obligations you're like why do you
get to be sick I need your wife here
right now because every woman out there
knows that the man flu is way way worse
than the woman flu ever is in fact
there's no accident I did not get the
flu because the guys get all the
illnesses and the mothers are not
allowed we have to build up immunities
before we get married and have children
otherwise the whole family collapses
foreign
the search is not an interview show it
is a conversation show there is a
difference and you see the difference
when you watch the show which you show
the episodes are unscripted they're
loose they're entertaining to watch the
now streaming episode with Megyn Kelly
become a daily wire plus member today
you'll get exclusive access to the
search plus all of daily wire pluses uh
hit shows and movies like of course what
is a woman good one for Trans day
visibility by the way joined today by
going to dailywireplus.com now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
following on this show the efforts in
California to instate a policy of
reparations for black residents of the
state attempting to right the wrongs of
slavery by according to the proposal
giving each black resident five million
dollars but as I asked a few days ago
why 5 million why not more I mean if we
have decided to enter into a fantasy
world where it's wise or even possible
to hand multi-million dollar checks to
millions of people as payment for wrongs
that they never personally suffered why
limit it to just 5 million well now the
activists in the state are actually
asking the same question predictably
from Fox uh quote activists on Wednesday
demanded that the state of California
pay millions of dollars to each black
resident in reparations as a way to make
amends for slavery and subsequent
discrimination dismissing the idea of
payments of 5 million per person as
nothing and too little the demands were
made at an in-person meeting of the
California reparations task force which
was created by the state legislations
signed by uh Governor Gavin Newsom in
2020. the committee was hearing comments
from the public as it considers final
recommendations to submit to the
California legislature which will then
decide whether to implement the measures
and send them to Newsome's desk to be
cited to law so here's a clip of just
one of the activists who is uh who is
not satisfied with 5 million here's what
he proposes instead
preparations are overdue for all
foundational black Americans
foundational black Americans that were
killed for nothing babies taken away
from mothers fathers killed for
protecting their families and families
broken up on purpose for profit medical
genocide unjust laws and just plain out
brutality
Foundation of black Americans have
helped every culture to get on their
feet now as it is foundational black
Americans turn to do the same for
ourselves not just for my generation but
also for the elders that took the time
and did the research and educated us and
taught us our true history also for the
field generation future generations to
come that will lead us into the future
with their heads held up high
I believe that 5 million in reparations
is too little for the work that
foundational black Americans have done
for this country and as well for other
countries I believe that 7.6 million is
a number that can be used very wisely in
our foundational black American
communities 40 acres is also still a
good idea and instead of a mule we would
like a tractor I also believe that we
should know the name of all the
companies that participated in slave
trade so we foundational black Americans
can start up our own companies
uh 5 million isn't going to cut it but
7.6 million now that would be useful
that extra 2.6 million that makes all
the difference you know the oppression
doesn't really start wearing off until
you get into the six million dollar
range and by the time you're at seven
and a half million it's almost entirely
gone
and by that I mean it's not gone at all
because as we know you know since we're
talking about foundational black
Americans whatever that means we do know
that one of the foundational beliefs of
the modern left-wing race Hustler is
that America is systemically inherently
racist in ways that are mostly invisible
and that black people will always be
oppressed no matter what happens Barack
Obama is oppressed Oprah is oppressed we
know certainly that Colin Kaepernick and
Meghan Markle are oppressed because they
keep telling us so which means that even
7.6 million dollars wouldn't actually do
a single solitary thing to heal the
alleged racial wounds that these
activists are allegedly suffering from
by their own logic reparations are
pointless
in fact they're they are most pointless
by their own logic
of course that's only one argument
against the reparations idea there are
many more and better ones I've outlined
most of them on the show at various
points in the past but today I'd like to
talk uh talk about and call attention to
a different argument against reparations
one that is by our culture standards
rather unspeakable
which doesn't mean that it's wrong in
fact it normally means precisely the
opposite a guy named Wilford Riley is a
college professor with a decent social
media following
um who also happens to be a black man
made this point on Twitter yesterday
here's what he tweeted an awkward
historical fact which genuinely
complicates the reparations debate is
that black Americans are just obviously
better off on average than we would have
been had our ancestors never come to the
United States pointing out something
this self-evidently true isn't
justifying slavery which was obviously
terrible for slaves and existed globally
in 1850 but no one arguing for that five
million dollars today in La is or has
ever been a Slave uh Pro POC affirmative
action has been the law since 67.
now he's not the first person to make
this point I remember I remember hearing
Dinesh D'Souza articulating the same uh
Point uh years and years ago and the
only thing that makes the point
controversial is the insistence by
disingenuous idiots to misconstrue it
they will say as was referenced that
you're justifying slavery or defending
it perhaps even advocating for more of
it but that is obviously not the point
the point is that the push for
reparations rests on the notion that
black Americans are in a considerably
worse spot today than they would have
been had their ancestors never been
brought here as slaves they say that we
must repair this damage damage that
black Americans are currently
experiencing they say to the tune of
five million dollars or 7.5 million or
maybe 75 million
black black Americans today are the
furthest removed from that historic
atrocity and yet should be paid the most
in restitution for it that's the claim
but this is a false notion
in fact it seems rather clear that black
Americans are doing better here today
than they would be had their ancestors
Generations ago never been brought to
these Shores we can prove this point by
simply asking which African country
anyone asking for reparations would
prefer to live in the answer of course
is none of them now you might offer the
rebuttal that if slavery never existed
if we're reimagining history without
that institution at all then Africa
itself would be in a better shade better
place and better shape and maybe indeed
black Americans would be better off
there but this seems highly unlikely and
it also ignores the fact that Africans
participated in slavery and the slave
trade as much as they were victims of it
not to mention if we're reimagining the
world without African slavery then we
have to also imagine it without all
other forms of global slavery since
African slavery was merely one variety
one offshoot of This Global Institution
and now we have totally at that point
Rewritten the history of the world in a
way so dramatic that it app it's
absolutely impossible to say which
individuals today would end up worse or
better in this alternate universe I mean
if you go back in time and get rid of
slavery from the entire world
you have just it's impossible to say
what the world looks like right now
actually what we can say is that we all
end up worse all of us today would be in
a worse spot
if uh slavery never existed at all
across the entire globe
because a change that significant would
likely shift the course of events in a
way that would mean none of us would
even exist it would be a world full of
other people who are not us
so I know that I benefit today from
virtually everything my ancestors did
and everything did to them because if
any of that had not happened there's a
very good chance that I never would have
come into being and as I see it I
benefit from being if the other option
is not being
so where do we land after all of this
um you know it's it's absurd once you
get into this conversation uh well let's
get rid of this whole huge part of
history and uh and then try to figure
out the equation of who's better off it
becomes immediately ridiculous
and what does that mean for the
reparations discussion well it means
that the discussion is totally
incoherent and stupid it means that any
reparations plan is an arbitrary policy
resting on a whole series of totally
unsupported and wildly speculative
assumptions about the way things would
be right now if they weren't the way
that they actually are and the best we
can say about that assumption the
assumption that blacks in this country
are worse off today because of slavery
is that it is a baseless theory but we
can what we can really say about it is
that it's a dubious conclusion based on
fanciful and pointless hypotheticals
so
maybe this all brings us to a different
conclusion
whether you're black or white
if you want reparations for the wrongs
committed against your ancestors who you
never met
you can have them
you can have your reparations in fact
you have them right now your reparation
is that thanks to the way history
unfolded good and bad
you now get to live in the most advanced
and prosperous civilization in history
and you get to enjoy a life a life of
luxury and comfort that would have been
Unthinkable to the vast majority of
humans who ever lived and even lived
today
if you are listening to my words right
now and you live in America
congratulations you are in the one
percent you are probably in the one
percent of the one percent out of all
the people who've ever existed on the
planet you are easily wealthier and more
comfortable than 99 of them
you also have more freedom than 99 of
them more opportunity than 99 of them
in fact no matter who you are you are
virtually guaranteed a stable and
successful life if
if you simply graduate high school
refrain from committing any serious
crimes
refrain from using hard drugs
work moderately hard and get married
before you have children
that's it do all of that we're talking
about the the the bare low effort
minimum
do all of that and you will certainly
not end up homeless
you will certainly not starve in this
country
you will certainly not die of exposure
or malnutrition
and you have an extremely high chance of
living a well-adjusted relatively happy
and comparatively prosperous life
doesn't mean you can be a millionaire
doesn't mean you're gonna be Wealthy by
American Standards but you'll be a
comparatively prosperous life
the world has never given more in
exchange for Less
that is a fact
and that is your reparation
so by all means go and claim it
or else you're canceled
and I'll do it for the show today and
for this week we'll talk to you on
Monday have a great weekend
godspeed
[Music]
the executive producer of the Matt wall
show is Sean Hampton our associate
producer is McKenna Waters the show is
directed by Mark Jones and Trey Miller
our production manager is Pablo vadoski
second assistant director Austin
mckellis the show is edited by Jeff
Tomlin Our lead audio engineer is Mike
cormina our hair makeup artist is
Cherokee heart our wardrobe stylist our
Kristen galaraga and Elizabeth Fox
director of production is Mathis Glover
director of Technology Mark Herman our
camera studio and equipment manager is
Patrick Kennedy our lighting director is
Keith Duggan host production manager
Matthew Kemp episode art is created by
Morgan Pierce our executive in charge of
production is David wermis executive
producer Jeremy Boren Matt wall show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2023.
hey everybody this is Andrew klavan host
of the Andrew klavan show you know some
people are depressed because the
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the Andrew klavan show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew klavan
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the Republic with me Andrew Clavin
anymore